on The Big Bang Theory Amy is the one
trying to push her physical relationship
with Sheldon along however she has no
experience when it comes to intimacy
since she's been sheltered by her mother
Amy is a late bloomer when it comes to
these things on her grock Nation blog bi
would often discuss the topics Amy was
experiencing on the show including
Notions of modesty boundaries and more
and over time her writing caught the eye
of the publisher of Penguin Books beic
was asked to write more about the female
experience as a whole and penned Girling
up how to be strong smart and
spectacular the book released in 2019
boasts a 4.5 rating on Amazon and has
been a hit with readers one Amazon
reviewer wrote this book is perfect for
you and your daughter or any female who
may need some guidance which we all do
she does such a good job putting it all
into a non-judgmental perspective
another reviewer wrote the author is a
mother but her voice in the book is more
of a mentor a mentor who wants the very
best for the reader however they do warn
that some of the content might be too
mature for pre-teen